we did a bunch of difficult questions in
this conversation let me ask the most
difficult one
that perhaps
is the reason you turn to god
what is the meaning of life
have you figured it out yet expect me to
put that into three sentences
we only have a couple of minutes at
least hurry up
well that's not a question i think
science helps me with so you're going to
push me into the face zone which is
where i'd want to go with that
i think welcome what is the meaning why
are we here what are we put here to do
i do believe we're here for just a blink
of an eye and that our existence somehow
goes on beyond that in a way that i
don't entirely understand despite
efforts to do so
i think we are called upon
in this blink of an eye
to try to make the world a better place
and to try to love people uh to try to
do a
better job
of
our more altruistic instincts
and less of our selfish instincts
to try to be
what god calls us to be people who are
holy not people who are
driven by
self
indulgence
and sometimes i'm better at that than
others
[Laughter]
but i think that
for me as a christian is it pretty clear
i mean it's to live out
the sermon on the mount
once i read that i couldn't unread it
all those beatitudes all the blesseds
that's what we're supposed to do and the
meaning of life is to strive for that
standard recognizing you're going to
fail
over and over again and that god
forgives you
hopefully to put a little bit of love
out there into the world that's what
it's about
francis um
i'm truly humbled and inspired by
both your brilliance and your humility
and that you would spend your extremely
valuable time with me today it was
really an honor thank you so much for
talking today i was glad to and you
asked a really good question so
your reputation as the best podcaster
has worn itself out here this afternoon
thank you so much
you